as evidence mounts the covid began in a
chinese laboratory social media's
crackdown on the lab league theory looks
worse
and worse we discussed what has changed
on the first year anniversary of george
floyd's death
and the media are fascinated with joe
biden's weightlifting i'm ben speer this
is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
slash ben speaking of which you may have
noticed that big tech cracks down
on a lot of your ideas big tech will
crack down on you if you disagree with
prevailing notions about for example the
lab leak theory and then
they will proceed to monetize you
they'll take all your data they'll
package it and then they will sell it
off
well one thing you certainly can do is
prevent them from doing that with
expressvpn if you've ever wondered
how free to access tech giants make all
their money well they track your
searches video history and everything
you click on and then they build a
profile on you and sell off your
sensitive data when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
however you anonymize much of your
online presence by hiding that ip
address that makes your activity more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers what's more
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your network
data to protect you from eavesdroppers
and cybercriminals
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it just takes one click to protect
all your devices which is why express
vpn is rated the number one vpn service
by cnet
and wired revoke big text right to your
data today secure your internet with the
vpn i trust for
online protection visit
expressivevpn.com that's expr essvpn.com
to get three extra months free with my
exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
right now to learn more alrighty so
the chinese government it appears may
not only
have hid covet 19 in their borders
and just held on to that information
long enough for covet 19 to escape their
borders and kill millions of people
but now appears that mounting evidence
shows that this thing
probably started or could have started
in a chinese laboratory
apparently this chinese laboratory was
performing gain of function research
where scientists take viruses they make
them more deadly so they can learn
exactly how to fight those viruses
except
the containment protocols at this
chinese lab were not proper
and so some scientists got the virus and
then proceeded to transmit it to others
outside the lab at beginning
the covid 19 pandemic that has claimed
millions of lives and completely
destroyed the world economy for a full
year
according to the wall street journal
just a couple of days ago three
researchers from china's wuhan institute
of virology became sick enough in
november 2019 that they sought hospital
care
according to a previously undisclosed us
intelligence report that could add
weight to growing
calls for a fuller probe of whether the
covet-19 virus may have escaped
from the laboratory the details of the
reporting go beyond a state department
fact sheet issued during the final days
of the trump administration
which said that several researchers at
the lab a center for the study of
coronaviruses and other pathogens
became sick in autumn 2019 with symptoms
consistent with both cova-19 and
common seasonal illness the disclosure
of the number of researchers the timing
of their illnesses and their hospital
visits
come on the eve of meeting of the world
health organization's decision-making
body which is expected to discuss the
next phase of an investigation
into covid 19 origins current and former
officials familiar with the intelligence
about the lab researchers expressed
differing views about the strength of
the supporting evidence for the
assessment
one person said it was provided by an
international partner and still needed
further corroboration another person
said the intelligence was a lot stronger
november 2019 is roughly when many
epidemiologists and virologists believe
that kova 19
first began circulating around the
central chinese city of wuhan now
there are a bunch of things to be noted
here one china did
two things wrong here if it turns out
that the lab leak theory is correct one
they developed the virus and allowed it
to escape in november 2019
and two in november 2019 they didn't
tell anybody about it because as soon as
china released the actual genomic
sequencing
of this virus within a week the mrna
vaccine sequencing was done so imagine
if china
had said okay we've got this thing it's
released in wuhan
right away and the rest of the world
said okay we're shutting our borders
right now
meanwhile developing that mrna vaccine
how many millions of lives would have
been saved how many hundreds of
thousands of lives would have been saved
even if you just move up the timeline in
terms of the vaccine development
to say august instead of the release in
november
you save everybody from that last wave
of kovid you save hundreds of thousands
of lives in the united states
so what this means is that the united
states politically speaking
now has an excellent club to wield
against the chinese government
and they should because the chinese
government is an authoritarian menace
the chinese government is trying to
expand its its
appeal to countries around the world
using its belt and road program
basically they pledge that they will
build infrastructure and help you with
your 5g wi-fi and all of this and in
exchange all you have to do is become a
quasi satellite
of the chinese state they've been
expanding their military presence in the
south china sea they've been building
bases
in the middle of the ocean by just
creating man-made islands
they're they they took over hong kong a
couple of years ago and nobody said boo
no massive international sanctions no
nothing hong kong which was guaranteed
its safety and security and freedom
guaranteed by treaty with the british
the british did nothing the west did
nothing
and the chinese marched right into hong
kong and just took the place over
and nobody did anything okay so this
would be an excellent time to push back
because
hell has there ever been a better time
to push back against a
an authoritarian garbage state than when
they just unleashed a virus on the rest
of the world
that killed millions of human beings
and and the evidence here is looking
stronger and stronger scott gottlieb
former fda chair and certainly a man not
prone to
exaggeration he says there is mounting
evidence that this thing came out of a
lab based in wuhan we haven't found the
true source of the virus and
with mers and sars at this point with
those outbreaks those epidemics
we had found the intermediate host and
it's not for lack of trying there has
been an exhaustive search for what the
animal
host was for this virus and it hasn't
been found so i think the the ledger on
the side of the lab
continues to grow and the question for a
lot of people is going to be when are
too many coincidences
too much when does it just seem that
there's too many things suggesting that
this could have come out of a lab
um and right now you know there's more
and more circumstantial evidence
certainly
so what should the american
administration be be doing what what
should trump have done what now what
should biden do well the first thing is
you don't make this thing subservient to
a who report the who was doing
propaganda for the chinese from the
beginning of this pandemic
first they suggested that it wasn't
airborne then they suggested that china
had done a wonderful job locking it down
they did all of these reports in late
january early february
the who is a chinese tool throughout
this process they were a wall not a
window they weren't providing
transparency into china they were just
doing the chinese bidding
they continued to propagandize on behalf
of chinese government
for months after the beginning of this
pandemic
and yet when asked questions about
whether the who should lead this
investigative process
the white house is punting the white
house again now the white house
has said i mean joe biden said in his
last fake state of the union address
i know it was garbled and it came out
not in english because the president of
the united states doesn't speak english
anymore he speaks
potato but the president of the united
states did say in that speech
that china is a rising threat and we
have to deal with that rising threat now
the way that
that biden wants to deal with the rising
threat is by crippling the united states
economy
and leading on climate change or some
such nonsense but here would be a great
way
to fight the rising and looming
authoritarian threat of china would be
standing up to china
using this as the lever to actually
effectuate change inside of china and
get the rest of the world to isolate
china
right now would be an excellent time to
do all of that see here is the thing
it's not that china is eating our lunch
because china is strong china is not
strong
if china wins it's because we are
surrendering if china wins
if china continues to gain global power
it's because the west has decided
they're just not going to stand up to
chinese aggressiveness
china's economy is not all that strong
it is based on extraordinary amounts of
debt it is based on being able to cram
that
down on its billion citizens okay the
fact of the matter remains
a chinese government is an authoritarian
horrifying
state that enslaves people and treats
people as chattel
and the fact that the west isn't
standing up to them is a is a stain on
us
frankly okay so how's the white house
dealing with all this they're saying
well you know let's not jump to any
conclusions here and they're saying
we are not going to launch an
american-led investigation into what
happened
at this wuhan lab and an investigation
into why the chinese covered it up for
months
now instead we're just going to leave it
to the who you know let's not jump to
any they're downplaying an actual
opportunity
to get the world to side against china
which is what the west should want right
now
here is gen zaki down playing this
an international investigation led by
the world health organization is
something that we've actually been
pressing for
for several months in coordination with
a range of partners around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
what we can't do
and what i would caution anyone doing is
leaping ahead of an actual international
process
we don't have enough data and
information to jump to a conclusion at
this point in time it's an international
process led by the who which is a
chinese proxy group at this point
and meanwhile maggie haberman at the new
york times she says well you know the
fact that we're downplaying the lab
league hypothesis and the fact that it
was downplayed
for a full year and that social media
was banning people that's really just
because of trump
okay here's the deal if in america you
are more concerned about the quote
unquote threat of trump
than you are about the international
rise of an authoritarian communist state
i think that probably you've lost the
thread here here's maggie haberman
saying it's really trump's fault that we
didn't believe the lab league theory or
you could have looked at the evidence
guys
instead of just yelling at tom cotton
about how evil tom cotton is from
mentioning the lab league theory he
could have investigated it i mean
you do work for the most powerful
newspaper in the united states maggie
haberman
part of the issue when this was first
being reported on and discussed
back a few months after the pandemic had
begun was that then president trump and
mike pompeo
the secretary of state both suggested
they had seen
evidence that this was formed in a lab
and they also suggested it was not
released on purpose
but they refused to release the evidence
showing what it was and so because of
that
that made this instantly political i
think that
it was you know example 1000 when the
trump administration learned that when
you have burned your own credibility
over and over again
people are not immediately going to
believe you especially in an election
year however
that does not mean it's not worth
discussing it's not
except that everybody decided it wasn't
worth discussing and i'll get to that in
just one moment first let's talk about
the fact that as a responsible citizen
you need life insurance it is just that
important if god forbid something should
happen to you your family needs to be
taken care of and this is why you need
policy genius
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place
why compare well you can save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius
you could save 300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google getting started is super simple
first
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need and
compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius never sells your
information to other companies policy
genius doesn't add on
extra fees and you comparatively shop
virtually everything else in your life
why would you rely on word of mouth to
do something super important like life
insurance instead
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
incredibly important
to get it right okay so the fact remains
that the media decided that they were
going to attack the lab leak theory
basically from the very beginning
according to a piece in the federalist
christopher bedford writing a new york
times business correspondent in hong
kong a weekend's editor at the guardian
who lives in new york a british business
insider reporter with a focus on the
saudis and an executive editor of the
daily beast
a 48 year old blogger who works for
rachel maddow a union activist who
covers extremism far-right politics and
media disinformation
for the huffington post and the
29-year-old editor of the arkansas times
a breaking news reporter at the
washington post who wrapped up her most
recent internship in may 2016
a 2016 university of pennsylvania
graduate who covers young people doing
big things for forbes a 45 year old
former george will intern who writes for
cnn and david frum what do these people
have in common aside from their
political ideology every one of them is
part of a machine that launders
smears and opinions through newspapers
magazines and television channels
presents the cleaned up product as
unimpeachable truth to the public and
then uses the freshman
facts to protect friends and hurt
enemies it's called the news and here's
how it worked for arkansas senator tom
cotton's completely plausible theory
that kova19
came from a chinese lab that hong kong
business correspondent
she wrote this headline for the times in
february 2020 senator tom cotton repeats
fringe
theory of coronavirus origins scientists
the slug reads have dismissed
suggestions that the chinese government
was behind the outbreak
but it's kind of it's the kind of tale
that gains traction among those who see
china as a threat
republican who floated virus conspiracy
says common sense has been my guide the
weekend editor at the guardian
dismissively explained a gop senator our
award-winning saudi investigator
declared keeps pushing a thoroughly
debunked theory that the coronavirus
weapon that the wuhan coronavirus is
elite chinese biological weapon gone
wrong
senator tom cotton flogs conspiracy
theory dismissed by actual scientists
the editor of the daily beast howled
tom cotton's failed threats aren't
really helping matto's blogger chimed in
so the bottom line is that none of this
was true because
they didn't bother to actually
investigate it in fact
politifact had a fact-checking article
you'll remember
they fact-checked a tucker-carlson
tonight guest who repeated the lab
league theory
that fact check was written by daniel
funke in september of 2020
funke graduated from the university of
georgia in 2017
he received a newslab fellowship from
google they placed
their student at the poynter institute
in florida which works for politifact
it's the it's the institute behind the
politifact
in his new job funk fact-checked a
number of covered claims smacking down
the largely acceptable lab origin one
more than once and making himself an
authority on fact
but here is the thing he was wrong and
now he covers misinformation
for usa today okay so the reality is of
course
that the media decided very early on
that the lab league theory was a bunch
of nonsense and then they just repeated
this odd infinite and they were just
wrong
in the same way that they were wrong
about so many things with regard to
covid throughout the pandemic because
they decided that trump was more of an
enemy
than china they decided that trump was
more of a threat to the country than
china and so anything trump said or
anything a trump associate said or
anything that targeted china must be
wrong
they went from china is a is a threat
to china is not a threat in record time
and now
they refuse to acknowledge that china
ought to be punished for what they did
here
china did in fact inflict this virus on
us regardless whether there is a lab
leak or not
china did not let anybody know about
this stuff even though it was
circulating since november
december didn't let anybody know even a
month would have saved a hundred
thousand lives
they didn't let anybody and now that it
appears that this appeared in a chinese
government-run lab
and that the containment protocols they
failed and they still didn't let anybody
know so they knew from the very outset
what this was that is what the mounting
evidence appears to suggest at the very
least
this would be an opportunity to fight
back against chinese dominance and
instead
nobody's doing it instead facebook
cracked
down on people who mentioned the lab
league theory
according to the new york post january
5th 2021
new york magazine's latest cover story
the lab league hypothesis concludes that
covet 19 is a human engineered virus
that escaped from a wuhan lab
the very same theory that moved facebook
to suppress a post opinion piece for
weeks last year
steve steven mosher only called it a
possibility in these pages
in february of 2020. facebook quickly
moved to suppress the column as false
information and wouldn't unblock it
until april 17th nicholson baker's
feature goes into great length on issues
mosher touched on
baker believes the virus was made more
infectious in the laboratory perhaps as
part of a scientist's well-intentioned
but risky effort to create a broad
spectrum vaccine
and then it accidentally escaped but
facebook's fact checkers put a false
information alert on the new york post
column in february of 2020 and blocked
posters friends from reading it for
themselves never mind the careful
caveats and the post on clear opinion
label
on the ps media figures accused the post
of spreading a conspiracy theory so
facebook shut this down
originally and it wasn't just facebook
shutting it down twitter
suspended a chinese virologist who
claimed that coronavirus was created in
the lab and fled to the united states
according to the uk independent in
september of 2020
twitter has suspended the account of a
chinese virologist who claimed coven 19
was man-made and created in the woohen
lab
dr li meng yan who claims to be a
postdoctoral researcher at the
university of hong kong school of public
health
had her twitter account suspended by the
social media site earlier this week
the virologist who had more than 60 000
followers on twitter before her account
was suspended
made headlines when she claimed to have
evidence the chinese government was
involved in creating the virus
twitter introduced a policy in may to
label posts that contain information
about kovic 19 which has been disputed
or is controversial the site said the
policy was introduced you quote
provide additional explanations or
clarifications in situations where the
risks of harm associated with the tweet
are less severe or people may still be
confused or misled by the content
okay so there are a couple of strains
that have crossed here one is the
pro-chinese bent
of so many people in the modern
marketplace and in government
and the second is the social media
willingness to do whatever the work of
the democratic party is
on a given day including shutting down
information being disseminated
that actually turns out may be accurate
i mean we knew that already okay all of
this is incredibly dangerous because
china is not waiting around china is
using its own disinformation processes
china lies on a regular basis in fact
the countries that didn't get hit all
that hard by covered were the ones who
didn't believe china at the beginning
taiwan wasn't hit particularly hard
because they immediately said okay we
know the chinese government lies so
we're just going to ignore whatever they
say and shut down travel
and yet the west was like completely
credulous about this something continues
to be completely credulous and continues
to push for the wh
and there are a couple of reasons for
this and we'll get to them in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that you don't
really want to spend a lot of time at an
auto parts store who would want to
you wait in line finally you get to the
front of the line they ask you a bunch
of questions you don't know the answers
to
and then finally when you do get the
answers they order the part online and
upcharge you or
you could just skip all of that and do
it directly on the interwebs with
rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into the store and
doing all of the aforementioned nonsense
instead head on over to rockauto.com and
just do it yourself
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact parts their family
business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog is
unique and remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands specifications and prices
you prefer go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we say
you get your vehicle in perfect working
order for the great
summer that is to come and do it in the
most inexpensive
possible way head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available and write shapiro in there how
did you hear about usbox so they know
that we sent you okay so there are a
couple of things that are crossing a
couple of sort of strains that are
crossing here
to create the space for china to
continue to ascend despite the fact that
it just unleashed a virus on the rest of
the world
okay strain number one is the cowardice
of the media
that refuses to investigate issues that
an authoritarian government tells them
are not an issue so long as democrats
are kind of soft toward that
authoritarian government
and joe biden for years has been saying
that china is sort of a
an opponent we're not trying to we're
not seeking to stifle their growth we're
not seeking
to check them they're not an enemy
they're more of a geopolitical
geopolitical competitor
if the democratic party has taken this
line for a long time then when trump was
president and became quite militant with
china
and became a lot more competitive with
china then all of a sudden
the democratic party shifted into high
dungeon oh how dare he shut down travel
from china that's racist if you say
china virus that's racist if you say
wuhan virus that's racist
let's go down to chinatown and start
just
licking people on the face to make sure
that nobody is racist against the
chinese because trump said chinese virus
even though every sentient human being
knows that what trump meant is that the
virus began
in wuhan and that the chinese government
covered it up every sentient human knew
that's what that meant
not that asian americans were somehow to
blame for the chinese government's
actions
but the democratic party shifted into
anti-trump gear
rather than into a unifying gear in
which we asked serious questions about
the actions of the chinese government
by the way there is kind of a high level
of bipartisan agreement that china's a
problem
and yet somehow this doesn't turn into
actual action okay so that's number one
number two and this is a broad and deep
issue
in the american economy the change in
strategy that was effectuated by
henry kissinger and the nixon
administration in opening china
at the time you can see why they did it
they were attempting to
take china off the chess board as sort
of an ally of russia
and then turn china against russia and
split the two you understand why they
were trying to do that
and there was a going theory that if
market forces were allowed
to percolate in china that this would
somehow effectuate an opener
a more open regime in china it turns out
that instead what happened
is that american consumers and american
producers and american business people
became completely dependent on the
chinese and so one of the
horrible things about the the expansion
of capitalism in china expansion of
capitalism in china has had a couple of
great things about it
and a few horrible things number one
that is good it has raised the living
standards
of actual chinese people by leaps and
bounds
and poverty has been greatly alleviated
in china because they have addressed
free markets and allowed free markets to
provide cheaper and better products to
china
at the same time however they've used
free markets in order
to establish a broader base
and a more strengthened base for
authoritarianism
not only that it turns out that
corporations
are not great defenders of free markets
and free market liberties they're more
defenders of profit margin
and so what that means that they're
willing to do business with the chinese
even if the chinese
are not truly engaging in free markets
they're engaging in mercantilism
right state-sponsored industry which is
really what the chinese government does
and so capitalism does allow for the
free exchange of products and that is
good for consumers
but what capitalism cannot do is
overthrow regimes
and capitalism allows for for states
that actually
utilize it to become more powerful
states that engage in the free market
become more powerful but that's also
true for authoritarian states that
engage in the free market
so the key there would be if you were
facing down the soviet union for example
to strengthen free markets in the united
states grow the economy extraordinarily
and then spend on the military this is
how reagan impacted the soviet union to
the point where they had to
basically pull out of eastern europe and
collapse
but if the soviet union had instead been
engaged in the world market if the
soviet union had embraced elements of
capitalism to strengthen its own regime
the soviet union would probably still be
around china is proof positive of this
and this is why it is so disquieting
when you see so many amer
prominent americans who are speaking up
on behalf of they're so
shy about offending china because
they're afraid that their market share
in china is going to go down
and capitalism has a set of underlying
values
but you can embrace profit margin
without embracing the underlying values
of capitalism
which is what china is doing and what so
many business people in america
are doing as well and that's truly
frightening right so for example john
cena
the actor former wwc star
right he j johnson wwe star rather
john cena he made the mistake of
suggesting that taiwan is a country now
taiwan is indeed a country
right taiwan is a separate country from
china and china likes this formulation
that it's basically one country
but that taiwan is is sort of an
extension of china
but taiwan is its own independent
country it has been
since the late 1940s when shanghai fled
china and mao took over in china
taiwan is a free state the united states
gives weaponry to taiwan to protect
itself from chinese aggression
and yet more and more we are seeing
celebrities who are coming out and just
doing the bidding
of the chinese so here is john cena
apologizing for calling taiwan its own
country
in mandarin
okay the fact that that john cena
came out and said he loves china and
that he is and that he apologizes for
suggesting that taiwan
is it's its own country is insane
right so what exactly did he do so
apparently
cena gave an interview to a taiwanese
broadcaster promoting a fast and furious
nine right f9
and he said taiwan is the first country
that can watch f9
cnn business says taiwan is a
self-governing democratic island but
china claims it as its sovereign
territory despite the two sides being
ruled separately
since the end of a civil war over 70
years ago beijing considers any
suggestion of taiwan's independence
crossing its red line
and has been increasingly trying to use
economic power to police speech on the
topic around the world
on tuesday cena offered an apology on
weibo china's popular twitter-like
social media platform
speaking again in mandarin cena did not
refer to taiwan by name or discussed the
incident in detail but he did say he did
a lot of interviews and made a mistake
he said i'm sorry for my mistake i must
say now it's very very
very important that i love and respect
even more china and the chinese people
now you will note that f9 took in 160
million
over the weekend 136 million came from
china
so the reason john cena is doing this is
of course because he wants to make money
and because his studio wishes to make
money
okay in the same way that the nba has
defended
china for taking over hong kong for the
same reason lebron james came out and
ripped daryl mori
then the gm of the houston rockets for
having the temerity to say that
hong kong ought to be free instead
lebron james great civil rights crusader
came out
and said that daryl mori didn't know
what he was talking about which is a
shock coming from lebron james who never
knows what he's talking about
but lebron makes his money from china
the nba makes its money from china okay
if you make your money from china then
you seem quite willing to
overlook china's human rights violations
so china is picking on a couple of
vulnerabilities in the west
one the west has lost a sense of
self-confidence lost a sense of its own
values
it's lost a willingness to defend its
own values in the face of chinese
aggression and so it refuses to call out
china and two
china because it can cram down suffering
on its own citizens
has been able to use its mercantilist
style of economics
its economically fascist style of
economics in order to provide giant
markets for foreign products while
pumping out cheap goods and services
making the rest of the world more
dependent on china than china is on the
rest of the world now the dirty secret
of course is that china is incredibly
dependent on the rest of the world but
the rest of the world never wants to
pull that trigger
the rest of the world never wants to say
to china no the rest of the world
doesn't want consequences for china
and so china could win this thing by
default china could continue to grow
despite the fact that it is an
internally weak economic regime
despite the fact that china is bordered
by countries that are not in love with
it
the the fact that the west has decided
to give up here and not press back on
what is a great leverage point
with regard to kova 19 in the lab league
and the possible lab league it's
demonstrative again
of a west that is in a process of slow
moving retreat
now meanwhile as we've mentioned social
media did a wonderful job of doing
chinese propaganda work
they shut down any mention of the lab
leak theory and this is just one impetus
for the crackdown on social media that
is now occurring around the united
states a lot of talk
by red states about what can we do to
reopen social media to the dissemination
of information remember all of these
ridiculous fact checkers shut down your
ability to disseminate information with
regard to the lab leak thesis
it's it's pretty amazing right the way
that
social media works is they have all of
these bullcrap fact-checking
institutions
those fact-checking institutions then
push out their own opinion pieces
quote-unquote rebutting
other people's opinions and then
facebook just uses those fact checkers
as an excuse
to shut down anything that the fact
checkers say shouldn't be on the
platform
so yesterday rhonda sanchez in florida
pushed forward a billy signed into law a
bill
that cracks down on social media's
ability to ban you now i haven't read
the bill
what i have seen in the bill i think
that it's got some legal problems with
it
but the basic idea that desantis is
pushing forward which is that social
media
cannot be allowed to willy-nilly ban
people on the basis
of completely arbitrary and obfuscating
rules
he's not wrong about this for sure right
desantis pointed out yesterday
you know that for for a year if you
contradicted the who on anything
then they would just pull down your
information well now anthony fauci is
suddenly signaling
that he's willing to hear the lab leak
hypothesis so so desantis is like okay
so are they going to pull thought you
off social media now
now we have information that this very
well may have emanated from the wuhan
lab
that it was a it was a leak from the lab
but you remember when people last year
were raising that
as something that needed to be
investigated they were de-platformed
for talking about uh the lab leak they
were
censored for having said that and now
even fauci admits that this may be
something that very well
um is the case are they going to now
censor fauci
and pull him down off social media okay
the corporate world is
moving in tune to china right
according to national review the
disney-owned studio searchlight
pressured the american magazine
filmmaker
to remove a quote from its profile of
chinese director chloe zhao because it
was critical of china's authoritarian
regime
according to a hollywood reporter
article published on friday speaking
with filmmaker about the inspiration
behind her first film
songs my brother taught me xiao said she
identified with the main character
a native american teenager looking to
flee south dakota's pine ridge indian
reservation
because she hoped to escape the
dictatorial grip of the chinese
communist party when she was a child
it goes back to when i was a teenager in
china said jiao being in a place where
there are lies everywhere
you felt like you were never going to be
able to get out a lot of info i received
when i was younger was not true and i
became very rebellious toward my family
and my background i went to england
suddenly and relearned my history
studying political science in a liberal
arts college was a way for me to figure
out what is real
arm yourself with information and then
challenge that too spotlight and by
extension disney then demanded the
american media outlet filmmaker omit
xiao's testimony
trying to appease its chinese business
partners especially because zhao
is the director of their big new
property
the eternals so zhao who just won an
oscar for nomad land
and she had said all of this
anti-chinese government stuff
and now disney is trying to crack down
on the magazine that printed it
okay china is going to win because so
many people in the united states are
unwilling to put aside greed in favor of
the national interest
and china is going to win because the
american government
does not even wish to stand up for
american values in the face of the
chinese authoritarian threat
that is a full-scale disaster area okay
in just one second
we are going to be getting to the
one-year anniversary of the
george floyd death what has changed
since then first
let's talk about if you are a business
and you are looking to hire quickly and
efficiently
really you have one great choice and one
choice only ziprecruiter.com hiring can
feel like trying to find a needle in a
haystack
you could post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along which is
why you should try zip recruiter for
free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire when you
post a job on ziprecruiter it gets sent
out to over 100 top job sites with one
click
then zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
including those of us here at the daily
wire we've been using zip recruiter for
years while other companies overwhelm
you with
way too many options zip recruiter will
find you what you are looking for that
needle in the haystack right now
try zip recruiter for free at this web
address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y zip recruiter dot com slash
daily wire zipper crew is indeed the
smartest way to hire
alrighty so meanwhile your garbage media
which continue
to cover up the situation with regard to
the wuhan virus your garbage media
continue
to suggest that great things have
happened since the death of george floyd
one year ago it's always weird to call
it an anniversary because an anniversary
sort of
connotates has positive connotations
obviously there are no positive
connotations to the
now legal illegally adjudicated murder
of george floyd
but the the media are trying to suggest
that great and wonderful things have
happened since the death of george floyd
i'm just wondering where the evidence is
of this
eugene robinson has a piece over at the
washington post today
titled the great work of art that
followed george floyd's death what
exactly is that great work of art
it is the giant painting black lives
matter on the streets
of washington dc says eugene robinson i
remember waking up june 5th to see the
words black lives matter unfurling
and 35 foot tall bright yellow letters
on what had been the southernmost two
blocks of 16th street northwest
directly across lafayette square from
the front windows of the white house it
was for me
an electrifying moment with her stirring
and audacious counter attack on
president trump dc mayor muriel bowser
showed trump how wrong he was she had
city workers block off the street
and asked artists to begin painting the
slogan around 3am once protesters
realized what was happening they joined
in
as willing assistants the moment i
decided to create black lives matter
plaza was when i came face to face with
a line of federal police blocking a
street in my legal jurisdiction bowser
wrote in an op-ed in the post later that
month
here we were in my hometown in the
capital of the united states of america
with people all around us protesting for
change
demanding reforms to the racist broken
systems that killed george floyd and so
many black americans before him but
instead of bringing the country together
the federal government was blocking
the streets it was clear the president
was doing everything he could to tear us
apart the plaza's importance says eugene
robinson owes not just
to what it says and how boldly it
expresses that sentiment but where it is
because of course it's a dead center in
the middle of washington dc
cities across the country admirably
emulated bowser and established their
own black lives matter plazas including
on fifth avenue in
manhattan in front of trump tower but
none equal the scale scope sl
slyness or perfection of the original
it's good bowser now has plans to make
the lettering more permanent because it
needs to endure
as long as does the nation it instructs
us eugene robinson
ah the glory the glory meanwhile the
murder rate in washington dc
is um is up tremendously i mean like
a large percentage murder rate in
washington
dc over the last year it has
risen to its highest number
in 15 years according to the
washingtonian
so apparently the legacy of black lives
matter in washington dc is a lot more
black people getting killed in
washington dc which of course is the
legacy of black lives matter all over
the country because if you actually
cared about black lives you might want
to pay attention to how many black
people have been murdered
since the rise of the black lives matter
movement which predominantly dedicated
to ripping on the police and suggesting
that they were they were the chief
threat to black life in fact if you want
to go to
the city where george floyd actually
died if you want to go there and see
what the legacy of george
floyd's murder has been and the
aftermath the blm movement their legacy
well it turns out that um the legacy has
been one of tremendous crime
and murder in the aftermath of the blm
movement which has done nothing
good for the country i'm still waiting
to hear the good thing that blm has done
for the country
i keep hearing there's a racial
reckoning okay so where is the good
where's the good that has come out of
this if the best you can come up with is
that a bunch of yellow letters were
painted
and a street in washington dc while more
black people were being killed in
washington dc last year
then i don't see the good that came out
of this
maybe you just like big yellow letters
but if the yellow letters say black
lives matter and more black people are
getting killed i failed to see
how exactly you have effectuated the
message that you were seeking to
effectuate
the same thing is true in minneapolis
according to heather mcdonald in the
wall street journal
19 children in minneapolis have been
shot this year an increase of 171
over the same period in 2020. their
relatives wonder where the protesters
are
why ain't nobody mad about a 10 year old
my grandson fighting for his life asked
sherry jennings
because a cop didn't shoot him is that
why minneapolis homicides between
january 1st and last week were up 108
compared with the same period in 2020
shootings were up 153 percent
carjackings were up 222 the crime
increase began after floyd's death and
has never let up
nor has the assault on law enforcement
that began with the arts and destruction
of the third precinct building on may 28
2020 officers are routinely punched
kicked and hit with projectiles there
was a near riot in downtown minneapolis
in the early hours of may 22nd
following a shootout among the club
patrons two people were killed in that
shootout
eight people were wounded responding
officers called for backup across the
twin cities at what the department
called an exceptionally chaotic scene
that we the previous weekend officers
were maced and pelted with rocks and
debris while trying to disperse
disorderly crowds so um
200 officers by the way have gone on
leave or left the minneapolis police
department
since may 2020. so right now minneapolis
pd is understaffed by nearly a third
same thing has happened in seattle where
of the pd has quit you're seeing the
same thing happening in new york
you've seen the same thing happening in
los angeles
so what exactly is the great legacy here
of black lives matter according to the
media which is celebrating the one-year
anniversary as though
this is something worth celebrating
number one the death of a person is
never worth celebrating
maybe one year commemoration is a better
way of putting it the media are
commemorating
one year since george floyd's death
suggesting that great
and excellent change has been brought
upon the united states where is the
great and excellent change
the answer is there is no great and
excellent change all that's happened is
america is more racially polarized lies
have been told about the police lives
have been told about america as
a systemically racist country and you
are told that if you disagree with this
then you are part of the problem
and meanwhile more black people are
getting killed this year so well done
everybody
well by the way the biden administration
has no answer on this they they still
cannot explain exactly
why how something good has happened this
year jen sackey was asked about the
rising crime problem across the united
states
she blamed guns weird because there were
lots of guns the year before
but it seems like only this year has
there been a massive increase in murder
here's jen sackey
is there a crime problem in this country
well i would say certainly there is a
guns problem uh and that's something the
president would say and there are
communities where
local violence and community violence is
an issue and that's one of the reasons
that we have proposed
and have now are implementing funding
for community violence prevention
programs across the country
unbelievable is there a crime problem no
there's a guns problem weird because the
guns were there before the last year
there is a crime problem
fostered and pushed by a democratic
administration
fostered and pushed by democrats in
congress fostered and pushed by a
democratic media
kamala harris vice president of the
united states actively attempted to bail
out rioters
in minneapolis in the middle of the
george floyd protests
okay and then yeah so what a great
reckoning we have brought here what an
incredibly great reckoning
in a second i'm going to bring you the
story of a black lives matter activist
who actually was shot in britain the
other day
because the story has something to say
about where the threat to black lives
truly comes from
in western countries we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about
protecting yourself so a lot of folks
own guns that's great but guns come with
risks that for example
tasers do not tasers line of non-lethal
self-protection devices
are small and lightweight enough to
carry with you or in your glove
compartment or purse they are powerful
enough to incapacitate
an attacker guns and pepper spray they
carry some risks
that taser just does not if you fire
pepper spray it could hit you could it
somebody else
guns obviously are more deadly taser
products are safer and easier to use
there's an electrical charge to
immobilize attackers for up to 30
seconds allowing you time to escape
and send emergency dispatch to your gps
location more than 237 000 lives have
been saved with the taser network of
devices start protecting yourself and
your family with taser today
taser is available without a permit in
most us states which also makes it a lot
easier
to use and obtain for a limited time
take advantage of tasers best offer
available and save 60 bucks on the pulse
plus bundle with a taser pulse plus
device cartridges
and holster at taser.com we have a taser
my wife carries it around so don't screw
with her
save 60 bucks right now by using the
code ben right now at taser.com
spelled t-a-s-e-r.com again that's
taser.com and save 60 bucks right now
when you use
codeben at checkout alrighty we'll get
to more in just one second first a lot
has happened in a month it's time you
took off the mask and watched a few guys
sit down and try to make sense of all of
it that is why you should join me
jeremy boring michael mosett walsh and
andrew clavin tomorrow night wednesday
may 26th
for another cigar and reason-packed
episode of backstage
in which my colleagues attempt to
imitate masculinity by drinking whiskey
and smoking cigars
and i sit there and i drink very girly
drinks and don't smoke it streams at
seven o'clock p.m eastern 6 pm central
on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel dailywire
after a year of authoritarian lockdowns
imposed by hypocrites who kept jet
setting around america while you were
trapped at home
you probably could use a vacation we all
could but you might get one for free
i'm serious when you sign up as a daily
wire member with code vip
you get 20 off your new membership and
you're automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip to the daily wire
studios to see candace owens live
not only will you be meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio our office and front row seats to
watch her take down leftists live in
action
honor to talk show candace this is
happening so don't sleep on it
go enter to win it candice vip pass
right now i get this question a lot how
do i go see candace this is how
enter to win a candace vip pass right
now at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20
off that's an awesome deal again you get
20 off anyway and you have a shot at
winning that vacation negoci
candace's show live dailywire.com
subscribe use code vip you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so this is a really indicative
story as to where the threat to black
lives
truly is a british black lives matter
activist named sasha johnson
was critically injured after a shooting
in london so
the original reports suggested that
perhaps it was political it appears it
was not in fact political it appears
that this was an act
of gang violence in which she was caught
in the crossfire tragically according to
the washington post a british black
lives matter activist is fighting for
her life
after being shot in the head during the
early hours of sunday morning
sasha johnson a 27 year old mother is in
critical condition after the incident
which comes amid numerous death threats
according to a statement from the
political party she is affiliated with
police did not name johnson but
confirmed a woman was shot in london
borough of southwark at around 3 a.m
on sunday now notice the washington post
coverage
if you just read that first paragraph
you would assume that this was a result
of the death threats
coming from political opponents but the
reality is according to the police
that there is nothing to suggest the
shooting in south london was targeted or
linked to her activism
detective chief inspector jimmy telly
said this is a shocking incident that
has left a young woman with very serious
injuries
our thoughts are with her family who are
being provided with support at this
terrible
terribly difficult time speaking to the
bbc on monday johnson's friend iman
ayton
said she did not think the activist was
the intended target saying she believed
instead the incident was linked to a
disagreement between
rival gangs okay so
this was not political this was not
people who oppose black lives matter
this was just
a gang shooting and that is far more
typical of black people who are being
killed in the united states and in
britain
than the notion that the cops are out
there murdering people
and yet the lie is that the the
reckoning the racial reckoning that has
to take place on both sides of the
atlantic apparently that racial
reckoning is about the systems of the
united states
here's the problem when you start to
dismantle those systems including the
system of policing
more black people die and that is the
legacy that black lives matter is going
to have to
carry forward here meanwhile our media
really focusing in
on the most important things the media
have an entire there's an entire article
in the washington post today called
weightlifting gatorade birthday calls
inside biden's day i mean this is some
heavy duty stuff right here from the
washington post i remember
when they used to write these puff
pieces about trump and what his day
looked like
oh wait no they used to write how
terrible he was for ordering two scoops
of ice cream and having a button on his
desk for diet coke
but joe biden man we need articles about
how fit he is hell with it i mean the
real
reason they're writing this article
about weightlifting gatorade and
birthday calls
the reason that you that you're reading
about his weightlifting and gatorade is
because you're supposed to believe that
the guy plays linebacker for university
of florida rather than being a doddering
old coot who can't string together a
sentence
here by the way is joe biden versus the
teleprompter as per his usual
arrangement
uh this is the the rumble in the jungle
battle royale
joe biden versus his tel this time he's
not even versus teleprompter
this time the teleprompter tagged in a
sheet of paper and joe biden gets
confused by a sheet of paper sitting
right in front of him
but uh there's you know there to be
you know beginning uh this effort
for 2021 is uh i think we've learned a
few lessons from
last year as well there's helpless
they're you know being there to help
clear roads rebuild
main streets and so that the families
can get back to their lives
that's a theme it does every single day
okay so you see a barely animate man
stand
stumbling through his own notes that's
what you see here's what the washington
post sees
during a speech in pittsburgh in march
president biden held up the index card
he keeps in his right breast pocket to
track the nation's cull of deaths
inadvertently revealing a glimpse of his
private schedule on the back side
9 30 joint video tapings with the first
lady 9 45 proceed to oval office
9 50 hold for ron shorthand for a
meeting with chief of staff ron clayne
as biden proceeded through the day
from a 30-minute lunch to a prep session
for a cabinet meeting he had ticked
through each item with a slash from a
black pen
check check check my god the efficiency
the massive virality of that guy
that man who again looks like something
from tales of the crypt right the dog
come on man and you know and the thing
and
click but according to the washington
post that dude is the most alive dude
you've ever seen he is so alive
he's like from the movie alive he's that
he is he is that alive
it was a rare glimpse inside the
president's actual life the extremes
the extreme scripting and almost surreal
regimentation that defined biden's days
from his arrival in the oval office
just after 9 a.m to his brief walk back
to the white house residence for dinner
with his wife by 7 pm
more than most public figures biden has
sought to keep one foot in the normal
world as he has ascended from the
he has ascended the rungs of power but
the presidency is testing that impulse
in an entirely new way
current and former advisors say biden
typical day reveals a creature of habit
with well-worn routines and favorite
treats
okay now they're just describing him
like you would describe your dog right
it's a creature of habit with well-worn
routines and favorite treats from orange
gatorade to chocolate chip cookies a
tactile politician
eager to escape the washington bubble
who meets privately with people who
write him letters the patriarch of a
sprawling irish catholic clan who
abruptly interrupts high-level meetings
to take calls
from family members it marks a sharp
contrast with former president trump
whose days often ran both early and late
with tweets that were frequently angry
or inflammatory and whose time was often
consumed by rambling rallies spontaneous
calls to tv hosts and random unscripted
activities did it ever occur to the
washington post the reason that biden
has to be scripted it's because he's not
alive
literally this week we found out that
joe biden said he was going to scale
back his infrastructure package to try
and make a deal with republicans
and then the white house staff said oh
actually we're just going to ignore joe
and no we're not doing that anymore
because he's not running his own
administration but the good news is the
washington post
has an entire article about how
wonderful and alive joe biden is the man
drinks gatorade
and he weightlifts too i mean if you
were worried that the guy falls
downstairs
let me just tell you he weight lifts
like a champ he begins his mornings with
a workout that often includes lifting
weights he meets regularly in person
with a trainer
his current peloton preferences are
something of a state secret but
apparently he rides his peloton
wow wow put that man
in in a triathlon that that's how this
is going to work out
amazing the propaga they are just
state-run media they are just state-run
media
all righty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon is the mat
wall show it is at 1 30 p.m eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam's psy events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
herrera and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant is jessica
kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show